[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett joining us today at the round
table of them lighting is Russian
American youtuber vlogger and
entrepreneur Olga Kay known to her fans
as moosh mommy Olga was once a
professional juggler in the Russian
circus and for Ringling Brothers in the
US since then she's made a presence
online with a unique ability to juggle
multiple platforms oh she blogs
performed sketch comedy collaborates and
she's got a gaming channel a fashion
channel she snapchats periscopes I think
that's a verb she's even selling her own
socks not like off her feet she has like
a line of Sun got it
she's a bein her one pair of socks no
she's got a line if there's a platform
out there that to be worked Olga Kay is
working it and she's been on YouTube for
nine years constantly adapting to keep
her content fresh and creative in the
process she's racked up over 100 million
subscribers across her different
channels we really enjoyed talking to
Olga finding out about her fascinating
backstory about growing up in a poor
village in Crimea and joining the circus
as a teenager of course we had a lot of
questions about the circus including
what it was like to clean up after her
aunts flock of trained geese yes her
aunt had a flock of trained geese I just
I love it when we're able to dig into
something like the circus because I mean
our brains just if there was like a
brain map they'd just be lighting on
fire lots of circus my talked about
there's a whole circus section of each
one of our brains I mean we talked about
the dynamic of her relationship with her
mother having to leave Russia I found
that very moving as well and then we
also discussed a potentially
controversial new book she's working on
that details an experiment of dating a
different person each month over the
course of a year that's interesting no
you're gonna enjoy this biscuit but
first we want to talk about our sponsor
that helps make ear biscuits possible EF
college Break the travel experts that
you have cause break create amazing and
affordable travel experiences for people
age 18 to 28 college not required now
everybody know the hardest part about
traveling is the planning
reserving flights and hotels figuring
out what to do when to do it how to get
from place to place dealing with
cancellations closures delays you don't
want to do this but you got to do it or
you can let the travel pros at EF
College Break take care of all of it for
you and then you're just free to enjoy
the trip and they've got some amazing
trips for you to enjoy across six
continents that's almost all of them
check out their website there's a cup
not there's not they don't have one trip
that goes over six continents they have
many different trips that would that
would be a monster trip to visit all
continents well but if you string
together a number of their trips you
could make it this is continent that's
true I check out the website there's a
Costa Rican adventure I recommend Costa
Rica there's a lot of wood there I
brought some back for link it doesn't
work well that's a ball it has leaks but
forget about that you're gonna have a
good time if you go European roadtrip
Grand Tours of Ireland Italy and Spain
and a whole lot more and they also
provide a tour director who's a local
expert so you know you're gonna get the
most out of your experience right if you
would have done that he would have been
don't buy that boat yeah that's gonna
leak yeah you're your partner in
internet payment it's gonna be upset
right because he was really excited
about it and then the the milk just goes
through the bottom of the cereal ball
remember even if you sign it by yourself
you won't be alone you have college
break Group C with other travelers that
you'll get to share this amazing
experience with so do it head over to
our special URL EF College break.com
slash rhett and Link and we'll hook you
up with an extra hundred dollars off
your next adventure that's right four
hundred hours off go to EF College break
comm slash rhett and Link and now onto
the biscuit
okay we are live guys we're rolling
we're not live actually this is not a
live show thanks for being on time yeah
you were early
um I keep hearing this thing how I'm the
only youtuber that shows up on time well
the only person who ever came early
that's for sure this yeah and I would
say that I would go as far as to say 90%
of people don't show up on time but but
as soon as they learn how to read I read
that quote from Woody Allen 80% of
success is showing up so I've just been
showing up I don't do anything else but
I show up so you learn to read by
reading Woody Allen screenplays yep
let's come back to that I'm sure we're
gonna get to your your background in
your story and I know that Woody Allen
screenplays will be an integral part of
a big but it's interesting if you say
that you are someone in your cause you
proved it somebody who shows up on time
it's usually not an aspect of their
personality they would have 60,000
unread emails you watch that video is
that yeah is that screen shot real or
did you fake that
no no that's absolutely real it's just
sometimes I look at emails and if they
don't sense the importance in my brain I
just ignore it and then I forget and
then there's a lot of things that just
went under the cracks because I just I
just forgot to open it a lot of via but
you means 60,000 there's a lot of cracks
I tried to concentrate on the important
things something that needs my attention
right away and if it's not something
important but you don't go back and you
don't do the bulk delete because it so
30,000 in that 60,000 is just people
saying you didn't reply to the letter
but you look but you but you peruse your
inbox and you see who it came from and a
subject and they do in the beginning of
the email or whatever yeah and a last
six months actually just moved and I've
been enjoying my life so I haven't
really been paying attention to emails
at all do you mark do you start to read
it decide if is important and then if
it's not important you mark it as unread
yes I mark it as flagged and then I have
to go every night I have this thing
where I have to go back and read all the
flag emails that's my system but then I
forget I would do that either so you're
telling me that the unready
are legitimately unread because the ones
that you've read but didn't read fully
or act on you there are they they're red
but flagged correct so you have 60,000
bonafide unread email well you get the
definition of unread here is important
because I'm gonna I'm sympathizing with
ogre here because for me I can end up in
fact very recently I had about 2600
unread emails but of that 2600 unread
emails I would say that 2200 of them I
knew who they were from what they were
about like I wasn't just missing emails
just kinda like you know I'm like I
don't need to look at that right now and
you do read the first three lines yeah
you get all you need an idea you know
you need okay change my system here's my
phone mm-hmm
let me do the thumbprint thing he has 50
unread emails that's impossible and
that's just as of today by the end of
today it will be like 5 or 0 because I
cannot if I look down on my everytime I
over my phone if I were you I would I
have anxiety that's why I stopped
reading it but I do have a new system
now which is came into effect only a
week ago and it's the system where I
read the first three lines and if I'm
not interested I just delete it without
even opening
that's my new system and then I keep
only the important ones nothing wrong
with it so my number will stay 60,000
until I go back and delete all of them
yeah but the new ones will be under
control yeah I mean so psychologically
for you you're cool with this 60,000
glaring at you yeah that's like 0d
exactly you know what I like it cuz it's
because if I have actually recently
changed the link system I currently have
83 unread emails so I've decided I
wanted to get rid of those and I read
through a bunch of them and then I just
bulk deleted a bunch of them because I
you know look at this subject but now
I'm a slave to this little red bubble
you know it's like I go to Goethe to say
zero it's never going to say zero it
might as well say 60000 yeah last night
I got home and you know I had worked all
day and I get home and I dinner with the
family
we ate some sushi I ate spicy tuna for
the FIR
time Lily got me to eat it hold on you
ate spicy tuna for the first time in
sushi yes because it looks like just raw
flesh I mean it make it look gross on
purpose I don't mean to digress here
Lily who just turned 12 she's like dad
just try it don't eat the seaweed pardon
oh you don't like that we just take this
I'm gonna eat it I was like you know
what it's good it must just be the
seaweed part so I liked it so but the
point I was making was I spent quality
time my family were eating some sushi my
expanding my horizons thanks to Lily but
then we come back home and everybody
goes to their screen and we we highly
regulate how much screen time our kids
have but they were away all day and they
were begging for it and they get a
little bit you know and but then I go
back to the bedroom lay down on the bed
because my phone was dying plugged it in
the wall there because that's where my
phone charger is and then 20 minutes
later Christy comes and she's like what
are you doing I was on my phone I was
like I couldn't hide it well listen I'm
I'm trying to get that red bubble down I
got to get that number down to zero on
my emails I've been we've been shooting
all day I haven't haven't had a chance
to get the to go through any emails I
might have something important in here
or I gotta get that number down so see
you developing lip session yeah it's
like trying to it's not he'll sleep on
top of a volcano that's constantly
interrupting you cannot win this game
let it or up let it you know like you
can't pay let it think you can do is
stop doing what we're doing
and just disappear and cut off the
internet will you just or get a new
email address Olga I mean just if you're
okay zero to sixty actually it's one of
the problems because I do have five
different email addresses excuse I have
I have literally 12 email addresses that
50 is across 12 email addresses hmm
I I could yes I always have this problem
but I have a better system now so now
60,000 will stay six a thousand but it's
gonna that's why we already heard that
you'll hear it again
hey the bigger problem here is its ulink
it's you yeah yeah we I mean okay so
that the healthy thing is just to move
on just rest on the volcano and move on
but you gotta move on I'm gonna be
reading my emails I was expecting you to
say that that was it was fake you know I
saw it and in the Seawind fig that man
how much photoshop skills I have to have
to think it was a funny joke except that
now it's real so it was just sad no it
was still funny well one of the things I
always think about is that you were
exploring the concept of speaking to
your audience and I think this is
something that Rand I have talked about
we actually talked about it with Shannon
and Candice on the hey hey show and
adopting a mindset of speaking to your
audience
I've been on YouTube for the last nine
years so there's a lot of things that I
went through where I was so excited and
then I developed a brand and then I was
just really burned out and I didn't want
to do it anymore
and then I still still had to keep on
going and I used to be I used to be so
much much more connected to my audience
before it was just no pressure I was
just talking to this one person it's
only one person that watches you at a
time because practically speaking when
you when you think about it hmm
we just have an in conversation but but
you're typically watching the video
alone alone in a bathroom on the toilet
or you were in your room I mean it's
efficient yeah you're finishing up your
day you're in bed and you watch that
video so and that really made me think
of how it's always just one person and
you should never make videos for this
giant audience okay I'll get overwhelmed
because there's a giant audience
watching you now it's always just one
person there and how does that changed
things for you I'm a lot more excited
and what really made me bounce back to
my old self is actually snapchat because
snapchat is a very connected experience
because you are holding the camera and
you're not sitting in front of the
camera I always found that even though
nine years later when I make a video and
I'm sitting in front of the camera
getting nervous I don't know what to say
I don't know how to open my video it's
just this weird thing but when I do
snapchat I'm very comfortable because
I'm actually holding it and I'm talking
to one person it's like you've grown
them by the neck pretty much and that
makes me very comfortable well you're in
charge of that point right yeah hey look
at this look at this it's a control
thing but let's talk about snapchat
because I mean we explored that a court
or digital from the standpoint of
directing snapper here oh but I I kind
of felt like that was a weird way to
have an it still having not used
snapchat I just write you know I just
admitted to now watching snapper Europe
but I was too late it I thought it was a
weird way weird introduction for us
because it's it's an interpersonal
application that you're one step closer
to using it I would imagine in the way
that it's designed but just as an
entertainer and a person all my
personality you're still you're still
twisting it a little bit so what was
your what was your first interaction
with snapchat maybe as a user yeah so on
the first time I used it was probably
two years ago and I really did years
yeah
when was it for you what never I haven't
used it but I didn't know it's been
around though
oh no it's been around forever and
originally it started did you know that
I would have said 18 months but really
yeah well - well it started off do you
know the origins it was a sexting app
where I knew the rap anyone thought that
yeah yeah so people only used to it was
never public but two years it was just a
private thing which I could never use
because I mean I don't want my nude
pictures to disappear after 24 hours
forever so I never really used that and
then I think two years ago it started
I'm actually not sure of one on one
public where people could follow you but
it took me two years to realize the
importance of snapchat and I think in
the last six months I started watching
actually well how are you doing it how
are you using it privately
no I wasn't so I tried it and I just
never used it okay and then once it
started opening up to the public and I
started watching my other friends
watching all this public profiles
and I was just so annoyed by them
holding the button and then they would
always tap on the screen with the other
finger and to me that was just so
annoying
and like this will never because this is
never gonna become a thing for me until
one morning I followed a couple of
people that I already liked and I
started watching it and I started doing
it myself and it was just overnight
where I realized that there's a couple
of people I follow Steve Zaragoza is one
of my favorite so okay yeah and he was
one of the first so I'm not sure how
long he's been there but I found him I
followed the wasabi productions and just
a bunch of YouTube friends and trying to
see what they were doing with it and
they were not really doing much with it
because they were not coming from a
traditional vlogging everyday world they
were coming from a sketch world into
snapchat where once in a while they'll
post something and I saw it as an
opportunity to vlog because I've done it
for so many years and the reason I
stopped blogging is because I was just
so tired of editing every night I had to
edit all the footage that I've been
filming and snapchat gave me an
opportunity not to edit and I just have
to snap myself for 10 seconds and then
it creates a story for you so at the end
of the day you have a whole file that is
all edited together by the app right and
the link is so confused he's like wait
what just being me but it lasts for 24
like 24 hours but they start to click
off so like each one is like a time
release of 24 hours yes
individually correct you didn't
accumulate a whole bunch of and then
blah blah I am throw them all up yeah
it's real time it's real time and then
what I liked about it you can draw on
your face which became very interactive
and fun and you can take pictures so
it's not just a video forum where if
people get bored sometimes it's a it's
this visual thing where you see a
picture and then you see drawing and
then you see video yeah well you know
it's it's interesting because the way
that you talk about it which i think is
the way that a lot of people are
successfully using it now it really has
the potential to sort of push vlogging
into this weird place where you know I I
logging in in a controlled atmosphere
where it's I guess I would say
definitely pure vlog yep
like blogging as kind of a as an like a
doily blog a daily blog where you're
like come and be a part of my life it
really doesn't make nearly as much sense
to do that in a edited video when this
kind of creates that for you and the
good thing is you can at the end of goes
away though here's the thing at the end
and a lot of people didn't realize that
but at the end of the day you can save
the whole file from your whole day as a
QuickTime file and upload it to YouTube
if you wanted to and then it lives on
forever so it's an archive yes okay so
you can do that but I just realized that
especially being on YouTube for so long
and seeing how audience has been
consuming the content and the more
people joining in YouTube the less
people end up watching particular
content because they're so it's
oversaturated and what snapchat is
training people to do is to be there and
if they're not it's like they were
missing something important at the party
if they go take a nap or go to bed so
they only have 24 hours to see it so
people come back to the app every three
hours to see if something new was posted
so they never miss anything so it's
great because your content is getting
consumed and I think it's gonna be
fantastic for brands because then
they'll know for sure that people gonna
see the message are you making any money
through snapchat or is this speculative
um you don't make money on your everyday
posts yet I don't but I have done
branding content that happened on
snapchat right so it didn't involve
snapchat you were just working with a
brand yes and it just like sometimes
will you know will tweet to go along
with a sponsored promotion on good
mythical morning or something like that
okay okay that's happening so that's
definitely happening and I think it's
gonna be a lot more happening of that
because every time I talk to Ethan my
managers own networks that are all
talking about snapchat so I think all
the advertisers are also thinking about
snapchat so you're moving on to
periscope so I don't even know what it
is I've heard a lot about it and last
night I was hanging out with Taryn
southern and Flula and we she was like
guys are you on periscope I'm like oh
gosh I was kind of like you guys oh my
god I'm not a
yeah your stomach just drops right I was
like oh I have to develop something else
now and figure out what I do so I asked
her is that like snapchat and she said
yes and I got so angry I just got into
snapchat I can't be doing something else
just like snapchat turns out it's
actually nothing like snapchat so Taryn
was wrong
she was a little wrong and you don't
have to hold the button but it's the
most interactive platform I've been I've
been on so it's a platform for
live-streaming and you can livestream
anywhere and you see little messages
from people popping up right away and
it's the app created by Twitter so it's
connected to your Twitter already and
when people and people can click on the
screen if they like you and you see all
this hearts flying around so it's really
cute for girls but then the brilliant
part about that app every time you go
alive and people follow you they just
get a quick notification on your phone
saying that she's live just click one
button and you're watching the show and
now you can interact with where does the
notification show up is it a push
notification notification just even if
your phone's not even awake yep and this
is all of our Twitter followers Twitter
yes so if you follow rent link on
Twitter and we enabled periscope
automatically they don't automatically
follow you but they would connect let's
say they open their app and they say and
they see who's on the list you'll be on
the list suggested list right away for
them because you already okay I wasn't
there isn't there another app that is
doing the same thing via Twitter like
people will tweet and then you can watch
a live stream right there in their
Twitter stream is this is that the same
thing I'm not sure because either I have
heard about this and I thought and I
didn't realize what's called periscope
or there's another one the thing I love
about this conversation is that a year
from now people are listening to this
right now
the right now is a year from now and
they're laughing at us in the way that
they're like brow furrow talking about
like talking if you're writing somebody
talked about the internet like Bryant
Gumbel
Katie Couric talking about the internet
year later you know if you're right
about snapchat if now is a year from now
they're laughing at us they probably
yeah or if we're if you're wrong about
snapchat no more right there they're
like ah they're like ah do remember that
for 400 it's the one with the the
meerkat is the meerkat the meerkat is
the no see how it is something different
look guys periscope looks like that and
then the one with the meerkat is just
called meerkat
yeah meerkat see so meerkat does this
well I mean not exactly the same thing
but I was like hmm I thought it was
called something else so what are you
doing on periscope last night so I
started last night and I realized two
things it's a new platform so everyone
that's featured brings me back to a blog
TV back in 2008 and everyone is featured
and and when you say everyone you mean
every I mean everyone who has more than
five viewers that are watching and then
depending on your popularity will go to
the top and I realized that the titles
are very important because a lot of
times when you start broadcasting it's
actually facing this way so it's not
looking at you so a lot of times this
the thumbnails are just the wall or your
feet or or something that is not your
face the toilet the toilet right so this
is the titles are very important and
then people just log in and the
discovery on that on that app is so high
when I was doing a show last night it
was just the 15 minute I just want to
talk to people and see what's going on
and half of those people were not my
fans it was just people browsing through
and they discover you and like who are
you oh we like you let's follow you and
see what happens so the discovery is
really high it's funny because know just
one thing on snapchat is missing for now
Oh discovery mmm-hmm I'm looking at a
graph that shows the percentage of
Twitter users using either periscope or
meerkat and how meerkat went up and then
just just recently March 21st
all of a sudden periscope just goes up
and passes it's like it kills it because
lots of YouTube person now
started to use it well another thing
makes me feel you know what when you
know we've done we have created the
email red bubble equivalent of social
media that is what we have just
discussed sorry buddy
you know we and now there's all this
pressure there's all the social media
networks that we feel pressure to join
and you know what the funny thing is is
we're over here just worrying about
email you you don't give a crap about
your email and you know it's a lifestyle
first of all we got to take a trip to
Russia yeah we sure like we got to go
get a get down memory lane but before we
do no you can't take us there but you
know as I said at the top you know you
we go way back my memory of you guys I
met you back in 2009 and we met on the
largest the largest collaboration in
person YouTube collaboration at to date
to up to that date certainly claim to
think we brought together more youtubers
for one video in person than anyone up
to that point I'm just gonna go ahead
I'm gonna go ahead and like claim to
that I think you're right though yeah
you were there and I like nine hours
you're right yeah I did anything for you
guys I don't even know who you were yeah
nobody's like yeah you talk about I mean
you get the wrinkly stuff on your
fingers after like seven minutes in a
tub like we had you in that swimming
pool fully clothed mind you because that
was the point for all day seven seven
hours yeah well no flesh started to rot
off of your like toes it's still it's I
still have problems but it's a constant
reminder of our friendship but there's a
it's a lifestyle to continue to adopt
and and learn and change constantly you
know and there's a commitment to I don't
know
it's its reinvent yourself or
reinvigorate your your creativity you
know we I have to think and you kind of
alluded to this going through cycles
mm-hmm No so I want to actually talk
about this is this is something that
made me think a lot and also be
appreciative of the fact that I did
stick around for so long because there's
so many times I wanted to quit it was
just too much work or I couldn't
understand how to break through or I'm
just spending too much money I'm not
making the money back or just like so
many setbacks but I decided to push
through until I'm finally like this is
my job now so the interesting part is
before I started youtube I was
auditioning and it was just a regular
actress in LA and it was very difficult
to break through for obvious reasons in
Hollywood but then when my YouTube
channel started to grow I came to my
agency and I said I have 50,000
followers maybe we should leverage that
and get me an audition in the movie and
he looked at me and he said uh if you
want to be respected in this business I
don't think you should bring it up like
the whole internet thing just hide it so
just hide it like don't don't
let's not so that was actually today I
left the agency and I never really
regretted it and I concentrated on
building my following for the next five
years so recently I went to an audition
and I have an audition in a long time so
I went in and they were only looking for
digital stars to star in their movie and
they brought in some actors and it was
very interesting to observe her the
actors were coming in and they were just
stating their name and auditioning and
digital stars had to show how many
followers they have before they got to
audition and how much value they can
bring to the project and you have to be
live streaming on parasitize but it was
just interesting how everything is
turning around where it's I feel like
it's not fair for both of them talent
it's traditional actors and digital
stars because you know what now really
good actors that don't have a lot of
following might not be getting the job
just because the digital star has some
talent and lots of followers so it kind
of comes a full circle mmm-hmm and you
know for youth finding making a way for
yourself and along with all of us
you started around that time just
figuring out how to make a living mm-hmm
there was the one thing that popped up
it was the Wall Street Journal article
where they were like tell us about that
it was New York Times oh the New York
Times article you know she's not she's
not making any money
yeah or you were saying I'm not making
any money well is it actually I can't
support myself
that's no no I can support myself I feel
like I make good enough money it's just
I feel that if I was on a TV show and
bringing the same type of views it would
be a lot more money so in and of course
they twist so was it misconstrued I
think it was twisted a little bit in a
way I was just trying to show that
YouTube community works really really
hard for their money and we're the
pioneers of the new platform that they
ad dollars are not there yet but they
will be but they had their own agenda
for the article so it turned out to be
like look at this poor girl working so
hard and not making the money because I
support that's all I do I don't do
anything else and I'm happy I'm not a
millionaire
from the article from fans or no nothing
from fans a lot of people texted me with
a lot of respect messages YouTube was a
little disappointed how the article
turned out but lots of agencies started
calling saying we're gonna make you more
money
come join us that happen yeah that's
like a whole different podcast about
that yeah the the offers of how we can
make you more money on YouTube than your
Arnie are and I feel I mean if you
compare YouTube to Hulu I mean YouTube
is definitely not up there with the
hoola with the whole um ad money right I
mean yeah I think I mean the we've kind
of learned how to is for interesting
having you know been the subject of
different articles you started learning
how to find the truth in media in a way
that before you actually were the
subject of them you just kind of assumed
that like oh this must be the case and
and what you learn is that oh well I
guess what they're trying to say is that
it's really difficult to do this this is
not a cush job you got to work for every
penny the bucks literally stops with you
you have to you know you're the one
who's in control this whole enterprise
and that's not an easy thing and you're
not gonna necessarily get rich doing it
yeah and that was my whole point like I
I work 24/7 I feel like and and it's not
because I make millions on YouTube I
love what I'm doing and I know there's a
lot of great opportunities that will
come from it so so that was my whole
point but you know everyone has their
engines yeah but you had a nice photo
shoot as part of it that was great
I looked pretty listen let's talk about
Russia okay
so if you tell us where you were born in
Russia we're probably like what is it
not if it's not Moscow yeah usually
actually you'll be surprised so that was
the case for the last 15 years but now I
feel like everyone knows that place and
I was actually born in Crimea oh really
so yeah so everyone because of the
conflict that happened there everyone
now knows that area so I was born there
by the Black Sea in a tiny tiny village
and that's how black is it was like
pretty black but it's not black at all
come on don't get my hopes up is the sea
bloggers have to go see it he is filled
with lots of seaweed that is really
black so it is it does look black yeah
okay don't let me derail you go ahead
paint a picture of the picture birth and
childhood yeah there so oh I'm glad you
brought the the birth I was born
premature so the fact that I can even
speak two languages is shocking to me
sometimes but um and the reason I was
born premature is because my mom had
really bad heart and the doctors without
her knowledge started giving her
medication that will cause the
miscarriage because they believe that if
she gives birth to me at nine months she
might not make it so I was the
miscarriage and I was two months
premature and nobody really thought I'm
gonna make it but I made it and and so
did they your mom found out at some
point
that I should I I don't want to be
taking this medication and she stopped
or no she didn't stop she just she was
just surprised when I came earlier but
it was because of the medication mm-hmm
that doesn't sound right it doesn't but
in Russia anything can happen
yeah trust me I've seen those driving in
Russia YouTube my butt so you were your
life was threatened yes from the get-go
mhm and then when I was two years old um
somebody left and undestood vinegar on
the floor and I drank it and I burned a
lot of my insights so up until I was
lots of things happen in Russia how does
this happen
what was that being used for to clean
something I I think maybe people were
cooking and not good I have no idea but
I was two years old and I was just
crawling around and I found the bottle
and it was open and I drank it and and
then I was in a hospital for a little
bit and I was my food consisted of oils
that were put in my mouth for like a
couple of months that's all i ate so up
until I was seven I was just a very
skinny scared little girl and I was very
shy and and what and what kind of family
are we talking about so I have a mom and
dad and a brother an older brother and
my mom was always very creative and my
dad was always a really hard worker and
my mom wasn't what did he do what did
you dad do uh my dad well he originally
he was a marine but then when the family
started popping out he just became a
marine like I thought that so like a
Russian Marine is called a marine -
that's the translation no this is how
you guys will understand it okay he's
not speaking of Russia
what's the Russian word for marine it's
been a while guys it's been a while
since I spoke my dad
I think it's my Rach very close okay so
then he started working in the field
which I feel like my dad always felt
like it was not satisfying to his
ambitions and my mom she was operating a
community center and she was teaching
all the kids
in the village different arts acting
circus and she always wanted to be in a
circus that's how my whole circus thing
comes into play she always wanted to be
in a circus but because of her heart she
couldn't but she had a twin sister who
was a professional circus performer and
when I was little when I was five I said
I have to become a circus performer your
aunt what did she do in the circus she
was a training geese geese yes what can
you do with a goose lots of things
actually they did a lot of tricks and
the dogs would do what how many geese
are we talking about it was at least 40
the whole flock it was so many it was so
many geese 40 and he's doing what dogs
do and yes they were ringing the bell
they were sliding on their butts on them
on slides they were doing the figure
Eight's between barriers there they did
lots of cool tricks and so my job when I
was 14
they put I actually researched how much
they poop and I think it's twenty four
times per hour or twelve times per hour
something like that and so when I was in
the village we just became so poor like
my life in the village was very bad it
was 400 people in the village
electricity was turned off every day at
5 p.m. till 5 a.m. so I was doing my
homework over we didn't have candles so
we had to make our own candles which
would be the olive oil and cloth that we
would burn and I would do homework that
way with my dad it was it was a pretty
was this region pretty poor in general
yes even now I don't even know what's
happening there now but in the water
would be turned off and a lot of people
survived on their gardening skills and
so we had our own cows and sheep and
pigs and lots of vegetables that we grew
in our backyard so do you consider
yourself Ukrainian or his I am Russian
technically because my parents are
Russian that's another thing in Russia
it's a little different just because I
was born in Ukraine and back then it was
it was not even Ukraine it was just SSR
yeah USSR and so I
rushon in my passport I'm Russian right
yeah okay so the in then Ukraine can I
speak Russian - I don't speak Ukrainian
okay you came Ukraine became independent
when like at some point during your
while you were still there uhm 90 was it
91
yes I just left okay okay so you didn't
necessarily experience that whole thing
but I'm sure I did but I didn't pay
attention I was a kid whatever
yes so your mom was a like a fine arts
teacher for four kids like you're like
yes like myself and I spent a lot of
time so he shipped with me also in music
school so my days consisted from going
to school in the morning then coming
home maybe doing the homework but then
go to music school and then go to her
community center and see what other
people are doing and hopefully get
inspired and not get into drugs and she
wished she was with her sister but
couldn't do it she couldn't do it yeah
she wished she was a performer so and so
she did you did she trained like one
goose well no so of my so my mom always
wanted to do an aerial arts and that's
what I wanted to do as well so when I
was 14 on the situation in our village
became really really difficult and we
couldn't be there anymore so we had to
what do you mean it was just no money
nobody was getting paid there was barely
any produce available to buy and the
whole no electricity no water it just
became really hard to continue growing
your vegetables and everything so we had
to leave and figure out another way so
we joined the circus when I was 14 and
by joining the circus our job was to
clean up after the geese hello Wow yes
so that was my job was we like your name
yeah my mom and my dad and myself and
because your aunt was already working
with the circuses she got you in she got
us you got us you got you the job
correct on the ground floor
weren't you working for her cleaning up
the goose poop yes and the goose poop
and then when I was 14 I realized that I
was too old to become a circus performer
because by 14 you already have your own
act
and I think that's when it started for
me that I have to work really really
hard and it was around the same time
when my mom told me that you don't have
to go to college as long as you work
really really hard if you want to be an
entertainer and that just stuck with me
my whole life
and I was too old to become a circus
performer so I remember going to school
and we would change schools once a month
and I would go to school and then I
would cuz you were traveling around
traveling around so much so you would be
in one place for a month hmm and then
you would move so the circus would come
to town for four weeks yep and was this
Russia is very different from America
and that's one of the reasons why I quit
circuses here in America originally
because in Russia it's a well respected
profession and we don't have tents we
have actual buildings built like the
circus and in fact when circus is not in
town really big pop stars use it as
there are stages to do their concerts so
in circus performers if you're really
good you were one of the celebrities in
Russia you are always on TV you're
always part of all the pop concerts so
you're just one of the celebrity and
there's multiple circus troops so we
have we have it's kind of like let I'll
paint it in this way it's kind of like
maker
we have maker in Moscow and they
represent all the circus performers okay
and then they send whichever people they
want to different cities in Russia so
and then you go to that city and you
work with a group of people and the next
city you go to you have no idea who is
gonna be there
just depending on what kind of program
circus is putting together so I often
would meet people and then we would
separate and I'll meet them again like
three towns later but we never knew
who's working with who so it's like it
was like fun always some people I've
never saw again so you're actually
performing with getting paired with
people not in your act but in the whole
program mixing mixing and matching
different acts together
yes it's never the same but but when you
first got there your aunt was like clean
up the goose poop that's all I hadn't
you know how long did that last and what
was the nature of that so I think so 7
o'clock in the morning we had to wake up
and clean up and that
take probably two hours to clean up and
then you have to wash the geese and you
don't wash them by hand you just let
them swim in them in the tub and then
they would come back into the cage and
poop again and you do it again at night
so and then I would go to school and
then we would have rehearsals in between
and then when I had free time that's
when I started developing my own Act
which was juggling and juggling is
something that I never thought I'll be
juggler I had no passion for juggling
but that was the only thing I was not
too old for and I just rehearsed eight
hours a day and I became really good did
you have like a master since a teaching
you my uncle was a juggler so he was a
big help in the beginning and I would
just watch so many performers I was just
so obsessed with performance and how
beautifully they looked onstage in the
in the ring and how effortless it all
looked and what kind of stuff did you
juggle just balls and clubs and rings
just the typical stuff and you can do
how many of those are done um five or
six well so yeah so I became really good
for six more than me I could you go one
yeah I can teach you this that would be
a riveting podcast but what I realize
when I came so I came to this country so
for two years I did that I traveled all
over Russia and then my aunt got a
contract here in America with Ringling
Brothers and I was in the middle of
working on my act with my cousin so
originally were just gonna come here for
two years and just perform with Ringling
Brothers and but that I saw it was 16 at
that time and then my mom and my dad
that was already established that they
can go so I can come so I can still help
cleaning up and then she's an assistant
pretty much plus she has a juggling act
yeah we travel with this flock of geese
yes do you send them out over the ocean
they fly their way to America or do you
put them in no
behind a plane flying fly yeah be
cheaper that way there were some
Traynham yeah go to Athens Georgia now
that was so cool great so yeah so I
traveled with the circus in America and
I didn't speak English when I got here
really what year was this 1999 and you
were how old I was 16 16 yeah I didn't
speak English and I remember our program
was put together of Russians Chinese
Moroccans
French Italian so everyone spoke
different languages and then but
everyone spoke English and I remember
talking to all of my Russian friends and
telling them not to ever speak Russian
to me and so I can figure out how to
speak English
once you arrive yes or in preparation
once I arrived so what do you remember I
mean when you first got here what what
did you feel what uh the first thing I
remember because somebody told us that
we were only gonna be getting paid $20 a
day and that was the first thing I
remembered where I was like ooh $20 a
day that's way more than I ever made in
Russia but I wonder what it's how long
that's gonna last and I remember was
last thing a lot like for $20 if you buy
you know a giant bag of frozen french
fries a long time so and I came to
Florida and it was Sarasota very small
town so I remember walking around and
was very quiet and peaceful and now I'm
realizing it's because everyone that
retires goes to Sarasota so that's why I
was so quiet and peaceful and I think my
third city was Los Angeles and we were
our circus was build in the middle of
Century City and in the middle of all
this right next to the mall so it was 16
I was going to the mall every day I was
making I think at that time I was making
two hundred and fifty dollars a week and
my only expenses were my cell phone and
so that was a lot of money for me
especially coming from Russia I'm making
two hundred and fifty dollars every two
months so it was a big deal so my whole
life was going to the mall
discovering things on my own
learning English I remember was reading
words every day trying to memorize it
and the memory of learning English was I
could not figure out the difference
between everywhere everything every time
to me that was just one word I could not
figure that out
oh you started buying Woody Allen's yes
how can I learn from and the other
members oh this is actually a great
story so I finished my high school in
advance because I knew I'm not gonna be
back for two years and I didn't speak
English so I can go to school in America
but in America you guys have this law
where you have to be in school until
you're 18 and so within the circus we
had a teacher that would teach all the
kids all these subjects and so they come
to me and they say so I'm 16 they come
to me and they say you have to go to
school here I'm like but I finished my
high school and their excuse was well it
wasn't translated so there's no prove
that you actually finished it so you
have to go to school so I go to school
but because I don't speak English they
evaluate me and they put me in the
second grade great at 16 I was in 2+2
and sitting with kids that are 8 years
old although they put you in a class
with second graders yes like an Adam
Sandler movie pretty much and I did that
for I think eight months and they said
no it's gonna be good for you you learn
how would you speak English like I can
learn how to speak English in my own
trailer I lived in the trailer too on
the circus probably like a start regular
yeah yeah what you wait a second so
second grade with other kids that were
more on a part of the circus art oh I
was pissed they like sent you to like a
public school with a second we had our
own school within the circus kind of
like I know she said where you'll have
your teacher and everything yeah that
was in the second grade so that's a
really fun make some good friends yeah
we're still really close yeah so that
was but also in the middle of all of
that I had to go to second grade and
then I had to rehearse and then I had to
clean up after the animals and then I
had to do the shows because I was also
in the show like pretty shows and
different
so it gave me a lot of really cool
insight on how to survive I guess
hmm can I make one little sidetrack here
I would be remiss if I didn't ask
worst circus accident that you
personally witnessed I actually been
personally in one was that one yeah
women also tell us the worst and I hope
it didn't involve you okay yeah so
there's there's two I have two stories
one of them was when I was 15 and I was
rehearsing my act and my act was not
just juggling it was me juggling on
unsupported ladder which is a six feet
tall ladder that you balance with your
body and you climb up every step of the
way and then you're on top and you
balance right it's not an a-frame no
it's just a lot of prop against the wall
and you don't prop it so you're just
balance it you'll walk on it okay and so
your feet are covering the top step not
covering but one is it front and one is
behind so that's how you keep the letter
in place and then I would juggle with my
cousin back and forth while I'm topping
the on top of the ladder well so that
was my act and it was a very unique act
and that many people did that for a good
reason
but we did it and one day we're
rehearsing something where I was
balancing the ladder while balancing
something on my head which means I had
to look up and look at that object as I
was balancing a lot of going on there's
like too much and then I've lost balance
and so I dropped whatever I was
balancing on my head and then I was just
trying to flip one of my legs over the
step so I can slowly come down the
ladder and as I did that my shoe got cut
and one of the steps which made me very
I was stuck to the ladder I couldn't do
anything so my only way out was to fall
back and see what happens but as I was
falling back the ladder because of the
weight it just slid under me and from 6
feet tall I just like blended on my
bunion on my wooden table like this on
my head
oh yeah on my head it was just like BAM
and then an elephant came in and sat on
you pretty much like no wonder I'm so
messed up but I remember opening up my
eyes and I felt so much pressure in my
head and I wasn't sure what was going on
and everyone was around me and they took
me to a room and for the next and I'm
not even kidding for the next maybe ten
hours I was asking the same question
over and over the only thing that was
important to me is what happened who saw
me and how did I get into this room
severe concussion
yes severe and I think I had amnesia I
was diagnosed with amnesia for 40
minutes of that time so I had no idea
what happened so then my mom my mom was
in there and then we went back to the
hotel and she came in and she was so
upset that something happened and she's
like what happened what days today I'm
like I don't know she said what do you
mean you don't know she was so angry she
didn't want to believe that something
really bad happened and so then we went
to the hospital and there was no major
cracks but I remember I was on
medication for probably two years
because I had severe headaches Wow
yeah so when I came to America and we
were traveling through before LA we went
to San Mateo and it was a Windy City or
right right next to Sacramento and I
remember all the winds really affected
my my head like if it was windy my head
would be exploding but that doesn't
happen anymore no I was good after maybe
a year in America then I was good and
did you stop trying to do that double
balance
I really didn't yeah after that I was
never comfortable and actually a lot of
people don't know this because they
always ask me if I want to do live shows
on stage and like no I have horrible
stage fright and like but used to be in
the circus and the whole career as a
teenager in the circus I had a horrible
stage fright so every show was a big
deal to me and I would go and I would
shake and I would freak out and I would
do well how can you shake and joke
exactly and your hands are get sweaty
because you're nervous so there's like
so many things that goes against you you
never turn that corner of nerves and but
then I once I'm off the stage I had this
adrenaline and I wanted to do again
now ago wasn't that bad I can do it
again but then every time the next show
rolled around like Akash can too so once
I discovered YouTube it was just the
most beautiful platform where I can hide
behind the editing it was just so great
as like mistakes didn't matter you can
edit that fall off for the letter right
now but what's the so what's the worst
that didn't involve you so what they
worse it was in my show with Ringling
Brothers it was a very professional
trapeze artist and she always did her
act without any support
so she met yeah no net and no wires
connected to her and she did this trick
where she was flyy and the the trapeze
was swinging back and forth and she was
hanging off of it on her heels not even
when you hang off on your toes the
Achilles tendon kind of yeah she was
swinging and something went wrong and
she just went falling straight down to
the ground
and luckily she had a guy who was right
underneath her and he grew up he pushed
her out so as she fell on him he just he
pushed her over so she damaged her back
a lot and but she didn't die he changed
her head first correct and you saw this
that isn't in front of a crowd yes it
was right in the middle of the show and
I remember our act was right after that
and I remember this really weary silence
and did they like just drag her off and
keep going or was there like no they
just she was there for I think 40
minutes until the ambulance came and
made sure nothing was broken was she
paralyzed no Wow
yeah she wasn't she landed she just
really injured her shoulder and your mom
came out it's like what day is it
yes do you remember the day what's wrong
with you get up and walk so that's
actually brings me back to the Russian
you know culture it's um you know
there's no like I don't feel good today
I should probably stay in bed from then
bed forever it's very like get going and
get things done so and vodka and vodka
well it's true for a lot of people I'm
not I always say I'm not a real Russian
because I I don't do that
did the show go on
I'm sorry yeah that was a low blow I was
just being stupid okay I'm used to it
linked did you have to perform your act
after they after I scraped her off of
the ground yes the show went on but you
know what's the worst part people sat
here for 40 minutes and watched him just
better interactional that's what they
could that's why they come in it's the
best circus ever for those people the
worst experience in the circus for me
was I was in Florida working in one of
those family circuses and she's a whole
different story when it's not a
corporate and it's a family anything
goes huh pretty much and so on that show
a man with a goat head I mean it gets
weird right it's really weird yeah and
this is talking to family circuses I
mean they've been in the circus industry
for the last 50 years like all of their
grandfathers been in the circus so it
was September 11 and I remembered that
happened and we're like oh the show is
gonna get canceled and it was like three
shows that day and we would have to
perform it was like the most bizarre day
for anyone but people came to watch and
we caught my bad what about sideshows I
mean is that something that did you
bearded lady yeah get to know these
people behind the scenes is that part of
it of course you get to know them you're
part of the troupe like I didn't luckily
you have any of that because I was part
of the Ringling Brothers shows that they
were trying to do something similar as
Cirque de Soleil so it was more of a
class fancier
I mean we had like a velvet chairs in
our circus right fancy I still dream
about it sometimes hoping that we can do
it again it was a great experience for
me when I was 16 through 19 I was
traveling with them and it was just
everyone's costumes were beautiful and
we all became friends and then enemies
and then friends again it's like a giant
family traveling for two years right and
how did it how did you end up staying in
the u.s. so in the in the US so I've
been here for three years with the
circus so they bring you in under a visa
then I
had another agent who and this is the
thing about visa so I was not allowed to
work in any other circuses other than
Ringling Brothers so then I had an agent
who did another visa for me that allowed
me to work and lots of different other
circuses but only circuses you could not
work like at McDonald's and then I
applied for green card and then with
green card you can do you can do
anything right if you get approved right
yeah so when I stayed in the sad story
about that story is it took me a while
to learn how to speak English and then
save up some money and do all of the
things that I had to do and I remember I
didn't go back home for seven years so
my mom I left when I was 16 and my mom
let me go because she always wanted me
to follow my dreams and then she thought
I'll come back in two years but I didn't
and you can see her until you're in your
20s yeah and it was really bizarre I
remember her calling me and I was trying
to figure out the whole like how do you
make enough money so you can travel
overseas and do all these things and I
was back before YouTube I was
auditioning for a lot of commercials and
I was trying to get commercial work as a
juggler and and eventually I did right
before YouTube became my full-time job I
booked five national commercials I'm
like oh this is it
perfect now I'll just sit there and
money will come as I developed the whole
YouTube thing but before that I was an
extra on lots of TV shows and movies and
that paid like fifty dollars a day and
it was working I remember working like
seven times we seven days a week
and I was trying to become a union
because once you become a union you get
paid twice as much and and that was
around that time when my mom called me
and she said it was a very emotional
time when she said I don't want to die
before I see you and her crying because
she has really bad hard and she was just
she just felt like she'll never see me
again
and so I I finally saved up the money
and I went and I was so weird because we
would talk on skype but we would talk on
skype all the time but then um should we
take a break okay no okay take a break
if you need to
um and then when I came home I remember
talking to them and I was just this
foreign thing because I was already
thinking and dreaming in English and
talking to my family I was just like I
can't connect like I can't connect to my
family and get used to the humor and
just just have a normal conversation
without trying to remember what words
I'm trying to use to communicate my
thoughts and but that went away after
like 2 or 3 days being there and then I
just made a decision to always go at
least once a year so you've been able to
go back every year mm-hmm
really I've been going every year now
yeah and then in the last I think four
years I started bringing my family here
so my mom been coming here she's been
here two or three times now and how's
her health she she had a heart surgery
um while I was in America so I flew
there for that I think that was like the
third time me visiting after I was
already living here she had heart
surgery and it's better they definitely
saved her hard but it's not perfect
mm-hmm yeah and what did what was her
experience this year for the first time
it's also very interesting because was
she proud of you she's so proud and she
doesn't speak English so she and she
watches my videos every day and she's
like make a video in Russia I was like
oh my gosh I barely have time to make a
video in English so she watches my
videos all the time the only thing she
can recognize is like like okay fine I
was like it's funny mom it's funny
there's another interesting thing I love
to curse in American like in English
but when I start cursing in Russian I
feel so awkward
because I think it's the length like I
have so much respect I guess for our
elders in Russia because I grew up you
know I just give us a couple right now
we won't even believe them because
Russians the way the Kurds there's so
much passion it's kind of like the way I
cursed when I curse in English but when
I say it does it feel like a little girl
who's like we won't know the difference
it's like time trust like partial Naju
oh wow it's pretty intense or she's like
oh yeah baller but it's the way I say it
it's kind of like yeah yeah you're like
you lose icon yeah
you should like totally be pointing in
my face yeah but I'll be like shut up
like I have like it that's in me but in
Russian I just like I just that with
little girls that's what you said to me
no no no yeah actually the second thing
was [ __ ] yes okay yeah I had to
translate now a little bit umm but yeah
so my mom when she came here she doesn't
speak English and what about eat goose
and I say that one okay
yes guv naive Oh Marie I doesn't have
the same meeting I don't know you know
sometimes it just doesn't translate the
way you want Boop and I just can't I yes
yes how do you say goose I'm actually
not that bad it's just I haven't spoken
Russian in like a week
so I forget goose goose yeah it's the
same word that's why goose goose goose
goose e goosey goosey is the plural for
geese anyways we'll do a Russian land
lesson some other time some other time
when I know Russian a little better but
so when she came here she was surprised
of how beautiful everything was and how
everyone was so polite and sweet and
like wait what is what do you think of
us and I just realized that there's
something culture that happens if you
are in that country the other country is
a painted in a different light and so
one day so when they come and experience
that for themselves or for her it was a
negative light yeah I think so I think
it goes for every country um and when
she came here he's like everyone's so
nice and sweet wait a second yes
whatever whatever the stereotype yeah
whatever news feed you and then you kind
of take that but they're said but
they're they're not in Crimea now
they're no so now she lives in Siberia
whoa yeah with severe safe but cold very
cold so in Siberia is the place where my
mom and dad were from and then because
of my mom's health we had to move to a
warmer climate so that's why we were in
Crimea and then she moved back to
Siberia but I don't know I don't think
it's really affecting her own health
that much I'm not sure what that was all
about but um but she lives in Siberia so
when I go to visit I either go to
Siberia or I go where my brother is that
which is st. Petersburg and then I'll
bring my whole family to st. Petersburg
because that's a little more fun yeah to
explore I'm not so cold in not so cold
yeah and it's just beautiful um but she
comes here and she loves it here and she
loves my dog she loves to walk around
she watches me make videos it makes no
sense to her but she supports it because
at one point I remember I think my aunt
would say something like why wouldn't
she just get a real job and then once I
started making enough money to actually
support my family that's when my mom
said I think that's her real job so
what's what's next what do you beside
besides periscope is gonna be my next
best friend
well a couple of things so one of the
things I've launched a new high tech
company also last year and I've run into
a couple of problems with manufacturing
because I decided to do everything on my
own and but now I finally back on track
so I'm releasing lots of new designs and
with that I'm developing an animated
show around those characters as well
yeah and the other thing and that's
something I actually haven't talked to
anyone about but I'm writing a book
about my dating experiment this is a
this is a breaking news on your biscuits
I'm pretty much you have not vlog or
periscoped
or snapchat it I'll say this I've
mentioned on Twitter that I'm writing a
book but I've never said what it's all
about it's all about people just assume
that it's a book about all the K
becoming all UK on YouTube but it's
actually about my dating experiment and
originally it started up an experiment
for myself because I've always been in
long-term relationships and then it's
it's how long can one person date Toby
Turner
[Laughter]
so in before Toby so I've dated somebody
for a long time and then before Toby I
was single for two years okay
and when I say single I mean nothing
happened but I dated my YouTube channel
I was working 24/7 and I remember waking
up one morning I was like oh it's been
two years and I haven't had a single
date and that's how Toby came into the
picture and then we dated on and off for
a year and then after we broke up I was
single for another eight months and like
oh there goes another two years and why
is this happening to me so I started
questioning myself of why am I not
dating around because people do ask me
out but I never go I never say yes and I
realized that I was terrified of dating
I can't do that I'm a relationship type
I'm only gonna date somebody who I
immediately feel the connection with and
that person not around I'm just gonna
hang out and if it's gonna be two years
three years fine and then I started
thinking even deeper where I thought
okay well what if I started having
children what is this want with the men
that I of my dreams what is one thing
that I regret and it was not to date
around so but then I started thinking
how much I hate dating so I had to come
up with an experiment where it gives me
an out okay um so in the experiment
contains of me dating for a year nothing
serious is just getting out of my system
so I never say I regret not to date
around and I was gonna date nine guys
and one girl before I settle down okay
are you in the middle of this right now
yes I'm almost done and and I would only
date each person for one month only and
I tell them up front that this is what
I'm doing this is an experiment that's
an experiment and if they're down then
we'll not play games not do this whole
thing i text you and you text me five
days later we just date and see where it
goes and then once the month comes to an
end we both go separate ways and there's
no hard feelings we both know it's
coming let's just have fun and you're
you're like on the dates taking notes in
your phone for your book usually I do it
after I try to be respected do we
know any of these people than this this
round oh the answer is no and nobody
will know anybody's names
oh so yes you're gonna keep all that in
private so yeah everyone is private and
have you dated a girl yet no it's coming
up and hmm okay I'm now my brain is
flooded with questions okay um Wow okay
you know I don't know what so I'm on
chapter eight you and your writing oh
you're writing it I go writing as you go
and what are you what is the nature of
the stuff that you're learning what are
you looking for and the men is one thing
but so it's you're learning about
yourself absolutely and also about
dating in general because I've never
really done it I've always been in
relationships it was kind of like I like
you let's date for five years that's
been my life in the past so I've never
really dated around and and I've always
been so picky and if a guy showed
interest is there's something like
control freaking me if the showed
interest I would always be not
interested I was like oh I'm not
attracted to that unless I was attracted
first and then he met me halfway and
then winded up dating okay so this
actually changed a lot where I was going
out on dates with people that I was not
fully attracted to but I was just want
to see where I would go so you would
intentionally pick someone for one month
that I'm not even attracted to this guy
let's not intentionally but they would
be like hey let's go out I'm like I
would usually not go out with you but
yeah totally I'm part of this experiment
right now you want to be number four
yeah do you want to be number four okay
so what happened with that date guy guy
so um different things happen with
different people but I would I learned
what I've learned about myself did you
find yourself being attracted to that
guy that you didn't wouldn't have said
yes to yes so the more is an interesting
thing about people if you spend enough
time with them you learn to love them in
a way like you discover little things
that are not there at first are you
living together - no just
just dating yeah and it just depending
on the chemistry the only difference
between all these different guys were
depending on the chemistry we either
spend for dates and a month together or
15 so you really hit it off with a
couple yep and was it difficult with
some of these guys who maybe you hit it
off with to be like okay I got to do
this experiment meaning I have to cut it
off at the end of this month yeah it was
difficult and were there tears with some
of these people like a legitimate
breakup yeah there is some interesting
we'll just have to wait for the book but
there's some interesting thing that
happened that I was not expecting and it
was just for me was just like fun kind
of like fun and games in a way and see
what we can learn from this and then
games until someone falls in love yeah
it became emotional at one point but and
you're dating this person on the side
and I mean it was like I'll just tell
you this I'm not going to tell you a lot
but it became emotional and I still had
to break it off and move on and what
happened with the next person was very
interesting to learn because when you
have to when you have yet when you have
feelings for somebody and then you date
somebody else it was just like it's such
a weird bizarre experience and how does
it and the whole time I was just
apologizing I was like I'm sorry this is
so horrible I'm sorry this is happening
but everyone knows so everyone knows
what they're getting into yeah how does
that impact it you know knowing upfront
well you know then I would impact you
well I'm a married man
I would imagine I want to date a married
man how it like I come to you I'm
flattered that yes I would imagine that
it would be reduced to okay this is just
gonna be a physical relationship and
some guy would be like I've got it I've
got a free ticket to a physical
relationship for a month and then it's
over
I think it's not gonna you know so
here's the thing that with that so the
first guy that I really wanted to date
was a guy that I never had a
relationship with him but we had a
little something going on and he is
known as the biggest player so he was
the first guy I went to because that's
exactly what I thought
like I'm already kind of comfortable
with him this is gonna be my first guy
so we just see where it goes and it goes
physical great and he's a player so he
for him it's gonna be like it's a
physical thing and then he's out and he
turned me down because he said he would
not ever be part of something like that
and so I standard and I was just like
what and that's when I learned that the
bigger your ego is there the more you
deal with things like that because since
their ego the girl cannot be in control
of something like that if that's they're
the ones who are that's a good point
control I mean there's also something
else at work is that why put your heart
out there to be you know just to get
hooked and then know that there's an out
like there's a yeah there's an
expiration date on this you and that's
another thing I've learned is when you
date somebody for a month it's actually
a perfect time to get to know somebody
and have fun and then if you date them a
little longer than that then that's when
it becomes where the feelings and what's
going on
so that's why for me so the longer part
of the story is and that's how people
kind of been taken that as oh they were
probably faking it out there not being
themselves when they date you and so I
decided to not tell people that it's an
experiment and just go through a dating
and see where that ends and the truth is
I feel like people are playing way more
games when they don't know it's part of
the experiment how many people have you
done that with just one person you've
been through that already and that was
just so and for me it was so frustrating
I was like oh this is what it's like to
date on our way this nothing happens and
everyone is playing games and everyone
is just waiting for something to happen
and nothing happens and then you're like
oh gosh
well listen we're gonna get the whole
book out if you let us so let's just
make a deal that once you get this thing
all down mm-hmm that we come back you
know well we want to read it yeah super
intrigued yeah and what do you expect
for that to be done and out so I'm still
so before I even wanted to you know shop
for a book deal or anything I wanted to
finish most of it so I'm kind of getting
to the close and so I'm just starting to
see if somebody would be interested in
the story like that and then hopefully
I'm in books I'm learning that it takes
a while to get them out so hopefully the
next year okay yeah or we will be
anticipating oh yes you're getting a
copy all right we'll hold you to it
thanks for hanging out with us and
making this biscuit it's time to sign
the table Oh waiting for this there's
your marker thanks Olga I know we gave
you a hard time but I it was a lot of
fun and there you have it are your
biscuit with Olga Kay let Olga know how
much you enjoyed that ear biscuit use
hashtag ear biscuits on twitter our
handle is at olga kay just like it
sounds
Oh LGA ka why you know speak to her it
means a lot when you tweet at her with
the hashtag ear biscuits she is reminded
how good of a choice it was to come and
spend this time with us today even
though we we may be press a little too
hard about that circus thing yeah I mean
the coz because we were talking about it
like the scishow like Lizardman
I mean like I guess some circuses have
sideshows that wasn't but not really
that's not really the circus thing was
the sideshow
it's not the show it's not society I
don't even know if those exist anymore
like there's a tent circus going off I
saw it on the way in today yeah and no
there's not gonna be like a sideshow
stages there but if you go to Venice
Beach or you can see there's a world a
smallest duck yeah there's a permanent
sideshow play that's another thing no
it's not it's not like the State Fair
booth it's like lizard man really at
Venice Beach yeah like there's a sword
swallower and he's just he's there
swallowing the swords and it makes me
think of the one person that we've met
that I'm sure has been in the closest
thing like freak show or sideshow Cat
Man remember when we and when we did
commercial Kings
we went and we made a tourism commercial
for the town of Tonopah yeah in the
middle of nowhere the desert and we
found out that this guy who calls
himself Cat Man if you just search cat
man on the Internet
all these amazing pictures of a man
whose face is tattooed with like stripes
like a tiger he shaved his teeth down
into points
he had piercing the restaurant he's yeah
he passed away that's the way last year
I think um we met him in a diner we he
didn't have like a sideshow he was just
like living and hiding not in hiding but
he was like isolated I guess he wanted
to get away from people right right well
he had I think he had made a number of
appearances and he was just like you
know I'm a cat I didn't I didn't do this
so you would you know come pay to see me
I did it because I just I want to be a
cat and he was an interesting dude I
mean but he was very nice incredibly
nice incredibly sir than most cats he
was a Gentile he was very nice he was as
nice as in dog he was very he talked he
had this like zen-like quality and the
way that he talked did and it was just
so he he actually altered his lip to
make it look like a cat lick do you
remember that the lots of surgical stuff
going and there were surgical whiskers
whiskers that he could screw in and make
it make them I'm not interested in doing
that personally but it's pretty cool to
see somebody who did I think another
thing I I am I'm looking forward to
seeing how this book idea of all goes is
received and also interested to see that
now that she's talked about it how
that's going to affect my theory is that
people will contact her because she
doesn't really talk about this publicly
people will contact her and say I want
to be next in line for your experiment
you know that's gonna happen yeah I
found an interesting house she's kind of
she's kind of changed the parameters as
she went on how much she disclosed at
the top of each month with each date or
not so yeah hopefully that comes
together for you book publishers reach
out to Olga I think she's she's
accepting offers yes and we're accepting
your ears every week you can count on
us we will not reject them we will not
reject her we are not rejecting them
leave us a review on iTunes on your way
out and we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]